I'm sure Xena and arranged marriage is
sort of like online dating yes folks I
said this recently and because I said
this I've been quizzed about it
incessantly to me it came from sort of
watching firsthand so many arranged
marriages happen in my life but also
watching so many of my friends who are
dating online and the more I watched
these matchmaking methods the more
similarities I saw between them what it
also made me realize is what a bad rap
arranged marriage has in the West
generally one thing I want to make very
clear arranged marriage is not the same
as forced marriage arranged marriages
are consensual forced marriages are not
so I found this amazing statistic that
was apparently verified by UNICEF that
55% of marriages in the world are
actually arranged that's a staggering
figure and it makes me think how
arranged marriages were really the way
of the world
just until a few hundred years ago and
in fact they happen still all the time
Lady Di and Prince Charles Lady Diana
Schaub so that was definitely arranged
maybe even forced then we have this 19th
century Russian painting of a young girl
being forced into a marriage now full
disclosure I'm happily married it was
not an arranged marriage and I did not
find my husband online however I I do
have a deep understanding of the topic
when I was I was born in London and grew
up in a pretty traditional Bangladeshi
family and when I was 16 they arranged a
marriage for me and before I knew what
was going on I found myself in
Bangladesh about to get married off and
I did not consent to this at all luckily
for me though I managed to get out of
the country thanks to the help of a
human rights attorney British Embassy
and other people but even though all
those things happen to me I still think
that arranged marriages can work when
there is consent so beyond me I look to
my bookshelf just the other day Jane
Austen Jane Austen explore
was the idea of romantic of romance
before marriage in a time when people
marriage for married for convenience we
look at Kathy from Wuthering Heights she
married to up her status even though she
was deeply in love with Heathcliff and
that reflects the idea of marriage and
the ideals of marriage in the in that
era in England we have Romeo and Juliet
where Juliet is is being hounded to
marry count count Paris even though
she's madly in love with Romeo and we
would know how that ends tragically and
I love the logo logo on this cover love
is toxic and lastly one of my favorite
books the Buddha of suburbia where the
Pakistani British character Jamila ends
up marrying someone she doesn't want to
marry because her father goes on a
hunger strike because she has a protest
to her resistance so scholars have
divided marriage up into four different
states so you have forced arranged
marriages where the individual has no
say then you have marriages that are
arranged by a guardian or a matchmaker
and individuals can say yes or they can
say no then you have number three
individuals who actually find their own
mates and then the parents are consulted
and get to say yes or no and then you
have autonomous marriage also known as
love marriage
will you marry whoever the hell you want
and you don't care what anybody has to
say about it in society so arranged
marriages happen for all kinds of
reasons there's a bunch of them what you
won't see here is love because love is
actually seen as a bit of a hindrance a
bit of a bit of a folly when you're
trying to pick your life mate so back to
online dating if you think about online
dating it's really a marketplace where
we go to shop and we go to sell and the
hopes are finding a potential mate well
that's what arranged marriage is - it's
a marketplace to shop and to sell
partnerships and I forgot what next
well anyway so anyway there are lots of
similarities I actually have a really
good anecdote when I was when I was in
Bangladesh I remember one of the things
I was allowed to do was like it was
allowed to peek through a curtain at
potential suitors who came to visit me
so I'd opened the curtain and closed the
curtain and hey who uses tinder in here
ring a bell
another similarity is you know a lot of
arranged marriages employ matchmakers
professional matchmakers who curate
contenders that's pretty cool you get
somebody who's actually a concierge if
you like and bringing potential mates to
you and on online dating if you like
that that concierge is is the algorithm
it's the technology at the end of the
day whether you have an arranged
marriage or a love marriage at all is in
the luck of the draw both